kovid turned our lives upside down but
after three years three months and five
days the global Health Emergency is
finally officially over this is a moment
for celebration at another level
this is a moment for reflection
covid-19 has left
and continues to live
deep scars on our world
it's a hugely symbolic moment the
pandemic overwhelmed hospitals turned
cities into ghost towns and challenged
so much of what we thought we knew about
Society but the virus is no longer the
threat it was no country has been spared
by the virus those in darker colors have
been affected the worst according to the
World Health Organization there have
been more than 765 million confirmed
cases of covid almost seven million
people are known to have died though
it's likely the real total is closer to
20 million so why call and end to the
pandemic emergency now well it is partly
the virus the original Wuhan strain and
the virulent Alpha and Delta variants
caused most of the mortality since the
Omicron Family took over in January last
year deaths have declined the version of
the virus we see now is highly
infectious but less likely to cause
severe disease and of course there is
the vaccine with more than 13 billion
doses given up to the end of April
Khalid is on his fifth dose convinced
the virus is still a threat I don't
think the pandemic's gone personally and
it's just to be safe than sorry other
health problems yeah just to be safe
than sorry
The Who warns Nations must not drop
their guard kovid still claims a life
every three minutes and the
shape-shifting virus could yet return in
a new more deadly guys Thomas More Sky
News